nella city ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vigente oggi siamo
tornati suo my thing regate da un bel
pezzo da novanta e poi sono tipo un anno
e mezzo forse non vorrei le cagate la
l'ultima volta che l'ho fatto per chi
non lo conoscesse le camicie verdi
mentre bisogna far indovinare gli altri
quello che disegni la cosa che gli
mancava ragazzi sono i nomi delle
partite che genera automaticamente tipo
prima regola le file dei club non
parlare le valigie che vagheggia in
mixtape primi on the boys di jol ragazze
voi sapete che è vero fa vice via ma
come rimorchiare con romiti non vedrà il
minimo stazione di quello che so fare
ragazzi perché sono quel tizio sbaglio
appena scritto viva fa vigente che
iscrivervi alla famiglia il pubblico
block prof
ma cos'è sta roba un orologio no capelli
che so io direi di lei di lady medie se
ho vinto non hanno avuto nessun tipo di
aiuto per niente come ragazzi è il mio è
il mio turno broken heart mar a braccio
rotto devo disegnare il braccio rotto
fatemi disegnare un braccio rotto come
si sa il braccio rotto ciò sta faccia
bellissimo prima di tutto facciamo il
corpo bellissimo poi il braccio normale
e l'altro
ecco viene in braccio il cazzo che
faceva freccia così più facile bene
ragazzi non potete non indovinare questo
capolavoro d'arte moderna ragazzi e dai
è facile farli non delle favi quello è
un ti pare che sono un tizio così ma mio
dio perché sono troppo brava di segnare
solo ora che non sono capaci indovinare
molto semplice fai qualcosa tutti
docente perché banana da casa casa
automobilistica di poco conto
ecco a quattro e tre quattro lettere
bookbook bookmark anzi sbagliato no
libro li ridò reed leggere il resto a
page page page come vorrebbe il gioco
voto voto voto
grazie non ho io l'ho indovinata perché
si capiva che era voto cioè nessuno mi
ha dato una mano neanche in questa
perfetto ragazzi sono troppo avanti
circolo jasmine ii che mi sta tenendo
testa però fra harrower rock rock si
vince che però basta basta una bella
fabio vinto cosa bella barba perché c'è
gente che scriveva da fare ma da quella
non mi sembra molto bella fa visse la
prima freccia prova ma è troppo bello
quando the queen mum agisce magis che
devo fare un mago da che ci prova lo
facciamo un mago come si deve prima
facciamo la testa poi facciamo le
braccia ma cos'è sta roba
va beh questo è un braccio un pò grosso
dai vediamo avere lo stesso poi c'è
questo anno il corpo il corpo di chi è
più fine è adesso ci vuole il coniglio
che esce dal cappello quindi facciamo
ok perfetto perfetto stanchezza una
faccia del tipo uccide fenice si vede
che è un mago e un po scuro no no ma non
è razzismo cioè proprio non va beh è
uscito così fa vincere win è stata una
partita combattuta ragazzi ma ho vinto
io non avere spettacolo me lo ricordavo
così divertente tutto bene e che
conversazione da premi nobel ma dobbiamo
giocare con selena gomez grande famiglia
hoc allora ho capito ho capito gran
basta però ma grazie cosa che cos'è sta
roba una scala land art
né ledere persone il cucchiaio spoon non
è cucchiaio che sta roba
e questo proprio a maglia zip zip zip e
un un un sì o un no sleep grazie serena
è bene non so saluto questo mini bando
che mi piace titanic che penso centro
titani pugno pugno puglia si fa quando
uno combatte incazzato quindi facciamo
la facciata incazzato beh il nostro
disegno lega aic è facile mica che
picasso non lo faceva così bene indovina
è fight si marmettola dopo bowling bollo
che questo è semplice ce la posso fare
tre buchi decenti perfetto di questa è
la cosa più bella che abbia mai
disegnato in vita mia alle porte di
scherzi dai cazzo happy face hayate
ziano sentita e coi baffi anche qui
perfetto questa è una happy face
familiari che pasta sei fatto zio forza
e da allora quattro lettere quattro
lettere che fanno ragazzi qualcuno lo
uccida sta dando i numeri aiutate l'uomo
che è stata dall'altra parte di questo
schermo lega a bruce bruce anno bush
cous cous cous cous o cecato bush e
obama se roba ma lo faccia un po più
scuro no non è pronto dorme ancora un
tabù ribbon fronte da faceva la porta
ancora brucia essere nominata prima bull
se devo rifare bush di nuovo ma
l'abbiamo fatta prima ecco ecco che
perfetta la vediamo perfetto eccolo qui
lo stavo facendo cazzola l'innominato
era abbastanza simile non ci sta
4 3 2 1
bush ho vinto è diventato semplicissimo
sto gioco presente e qualsiasi cosa tu
scelga esce pulci al caso quindi provato
prova a disegnare un pene voglio vedere
se indovini grazie o fuori ad indovinare
busso ragazzi ho vinto la partita non si
sa come va bene va bene così ma non
funziona se veramente fa vita in no non
sono favi jason george bush alla ragazzi
vogliamo fare così bene
venus ma non sono ne va a venere
potrebbe rovinare bene allora mi sembra
un po strano eh no forse e venus
williams venus williams perfetto questa
qui facciamo venus williams
eccola eccola qui questa e venus
williams non potete non indovinarla
perché precisa e lei è la semplice cazzo
me ne sono un indovino e mi sono
documentato ci ho provato a impossibile
linea caso linea caso a caso per caso ti
di segnali in grigio che prodotto non
l'ho capita sta cosa è una mattonata
tavolo tavo table cable no box box box
sì so cos'è sta roba degli andate mila
ma mère sheet non è non è merda cos'è
cos'è una roba del genere spiega tema di
questo questo c'azzecca toe dog she wolf
che cazzo ne so la coda bella la coda
cavallo promossa
forse forse sì che un cavallo mi
sembravano proprio però va bene va bene
così ho pensato ha professato horses sin
da subito ma mi sembrava una stronzata
prova bella faccia non lo so mi mittens
che cazzo vuol dire mettere quanti
quanti quando lo sapevo ma quanti quanti
facciamo facciamo questi nokia blog mi
chiamare lo sto facendo meglio di così
non potevo farlo da casa non indovina ti
vengo a prendere a cazzotti senza guanti
tra l'altro per i perfetto bravo c'è 11
la indovinato a me non mi sento un
completo idiota
anche se dyson guanti vita si capisce a
parte che sembrano due tizi che si
abbracciano senza testa hanno cinto di
sicurezza cintura di sicurezza però c'è
beh seat belt seat belt
si dovrebbe l'ho presa per ultimo da
tutti hanno indovinata io ho dovuto
andare a cercare fantastico è che non
sapere l'inglese che cazzo succede vale
io sono più lenta ciò che alle cose
maledetti scarabocchi explore the è
svolto a caso a caso ho scritto il suo
caso berlusconi anche inglese luridi
questo tutti inglesi tranquilli che fu
sfidando le sale sono primo io tra
l'altro ho mai dico per la cacca la so
disegnare bene famiglie tra tutte le
parole ragazze ovviamente mi è uscito
punto è che sono una bella cagata
fumante papa appena faccia anche il culo
del cane se vuoi questo è il buco del
questa è una carta che trovi ovviamente
sul marciapiede che spero tu presti
domani perfetto iscritti
ho fatto incrinare sta merda sa bene
bene bene ho vinto io ragazzi ho vinto
con la pur ovviamente il mio cavallo di
battaglia di segnare nel pool e una
mantide religiosa
mi sembra un coyote schiacciato da un
camion con desk desk desk desk no era
gassman
una maschera antigas cazzo se si
somiglia lega coltello coltello da chi
ce la faccio fare un coltello decente
questo questo è un coltello schifo fatto
anche il coltello col manico girato
michia meglio di così madonna ris se non
indovinate lo prendo va al coltello io
non è non è possibile come fatto è
troppo bello l'ho fatto troppo bene cioè
faccio anche il sangue guarda del sangue
che cola
il sangue di sangue vostro sono un
indovinato è sta roba dai cazzo e
coltello mi chiama lasciamo ad un genio
blood si vabbè poi le sangue ma quel
tutto il resto sword cazzo ma ministro
una spada con un coso minuscolo forse si
è abituato al top è ne vuole ancora
sguardo prodotti ma lui è stupida o cosa
che non è possibile a bab ramla chulack
braccia grecia lett
non è braccialetto come si dice
braccialetto orologio orologio era
braccialetto scritto io farei marazzi a
letto ma [ __ ] vabbè ragazzi nation
perdere flash a led
direi che fosse conclude qui lega perché
credo abbiate apprezzato le mie doti da
picasso perché si apprezza tutti ragazzi
re che possono chiudere qui sta il video
è piaciuta una salita lasciato un
momento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook come non i video trovate nelle
sezione forse dovresti discrimine ci
vediamo al prossimo vito era ragazzi